(upbeat music)
- I think it's fun, making passwords;
I don't like to do it from
9AM to 10 o'clock at night,
but that's what comes
with having a business,
you do the orders,
you don't just get
money for doing nothing.
Welcome to Keeping Up
With The Modi/Egglands.
My name is Mira Modi, and
I love password making,
as you know.
One big happy family.
I make passwords that are very secure,
and I have a website where
I sell them for $2 each
and I send them by postal mail.
I roll dice to make strings of numbers,
use the string of numbers
to get corresponding words
in the diceware dictionary.
I roll dice five times for each word,
so you do that six times for one password.
So, I roll dice 30 times
and it produces random word
that have a lot of entropy,
which means it's not easy
for the computer to hack.
Kind of, like, turned into a thing I would do
like, if my mom's friends are like come over,
and they're like hey, can you
make me a couple passwords,
and I'd do it.
Then I was like, “Oh, let's
make it into a website.”
And here I am,
and the website is kicking off,
and I'm really excited about that.
Some people, like, say being popular in school
is the best thing ever,
I think this is so much better.
People actually learn
from this and that's good.